this is like our Christmas it's a most
important week of the year for us and
there's billions of dollars of collector
cars here there are thousands of cars on
display here and thousands of cars that
are for sale what this started off as
out in Monterey is a conqueror which is
a car show where the cars are judged and
then these auctions kind of came to town
a number of years ago and it's created
this gravity for the events in Monterey
where this is the place that the world
watches to see how the car market is
doing and not just to see which cars are
the prettiest will you paint it with a
10 inch brush you say the market is
doing very well and that's true when you
drill down you can see that certain
makes of cars have been performing that
much better than other types of cars we
know Ferraris have been on an ascendancy
and generally speaking when a Ferrari
does that the comparable Maserati goes
up as well so they're kind of
index-linked everybody's talking about
Ferrari but there are also so many other
cars that are doing very well at our
auctions the Mercedes mark has been
doing very well porsche jaguar all of
the really the european sports and
racing cars
the benefit of collector cars is unlike
buying a yacht or unlike buying a new
jet we're here of course playing a
depreciation game you may have to pay a
good amount of money for it but it's
that car is almost guaranteed to either
hold its value or go up in value we
always encourage people to buy a car
that they love because whether it goes
up and down in value you know they may
own it for a long time it's all about
the love of the car and sharing it with
other enthusiasts I don't think any car
was ever purchased with a resale value